16:18 and bohemia here is in revolt at
this point Bohemia formed an important
part of the Holy Roman Empire and had
since the Protestant Reformation moved
steadily away from Catholicism much of
this was thanks to their prior rulers
such as Matthew so allowed the
Protestants greater freedom of worship
this was built upon the previous 1555
Peace of Augsburg which allowed for
rulers of territories within the Holy
Roman Empire to choose its religious
denomination so long as that
denomination was Catholicism or
Lutheranism that is Mathias didn't have
any children and so appointed an heir
Ferdinand of Styria the Archduke of
Austria who succeeded him as King of
Bohemia in 1617 Ferdinand was a devout
Catholic and so sent representatives to
bohemia' to shut down the Protestant
churches and demand the conversion of
its nobles the Bohemians had a clever
way of countering this they threw
Ferdinand's representatives out of a
third-story window an event known as the
second defenestration of Prague because
this was not the first time people have
been thrown out of a window for
religious reasons
Ferdinand unsurprisingly was unhappy
that his representatives who survived by
the way were treated as such
bohemia' was thus plunged into a civil
war many of the Holy Roman Empire's
Catholic states were dragged into the
war as well
Bohemia was aided by these states
notably the Palatinate and Transylvania
and were given financial aid by the
Netherlands it's worth noting that there
were other Protestant states within the
Empire the most notable being Saxony who
remained neutral because they didn't
want any trouble
Spain and its territories led also by
the Habsburg join the war on the side of
their German relatives and things
weren't looking good for Bohemia so the
leader of the Bohemian rebels was
Heinrich Cerne who reached out to
Frederick of the Palatinate who in 1619
was crowned as king of bohemia bohemia'
was reaching out to other major
protestant powers like England Sweden
and Denmark Norway but they were very
cautious and didn't approve of
Frederick's actions with the King of
Denmark Christian the fourth asking him
who advised you to drive out kings and
seize kingdoms in the same year
Ferdinand was made Holy Roman Emperor
and third even managed to march on
Vienna but to no avail 1620 saw the
Bohemian revolt crushed at the decisive
battle of the white mountain with the
Imperial forces being led by johann
circus the count of Tilly as a result
the Bohemian leadership fled in
Transylvania made peace which left the
Palatinate as the only major resisting
state resistance continued there until
1622 when it was conquered and the
majority of the Protestant forces were
pushed out of the Empire the next year
sporadic fighting continued but was
crushed by 1625 our sending the first
phase of the war could the Bohemian
phase there was however now a power
war running between Spain and the
Netherlands who had resumed the eighty
Years War it seemed that this would be
the end of the conflict but King
Christian who also held lands in the
Empire was concerned the Protestants
would be persecuted severely he decided
to intervene in 1625 marching his army
down south two-faced hilly in another
Habsburg general outbreak from Valen
Steen a Catholic bohemian who made lot
of money by seizing Protestant lands
there this began the second phase of the
war the Danish phase Christians
intervention went poorly and he was
subject to continuous defeats at the
hands of both Chilean volunteen and he
was pushed back into Denmark Christian
had expected his fellow Protestant kings
in Sweden and England to back him but
both had failed to do so
demet was also backed financially by the
French who as you'll note were Catholic
meaning that this war was about more
than religion the French simply wanted
to weaken the Habsburg neighbors but the
support had to stop when their own
Protestant population the Hyuga nose
revolted in 1629 Christian the fourth
signed the treaty of Lloyd Beck which
allowed him to keep his territories on
the condition that he stay out of the
affairs of the Empire the problem still
remained that the Protestant domains of
Europe were concerned about a powerful
Catholic Empire neighboring them the
mantle of defending Protestants fell to
the Swedish King Gustav ii better known
as Gustavus Adolphus who art the
finishing a war with the Polish
Lithuanian Commonwealth decided to
intervene much like Christian the fourth
Gustavus also received financial help
from the French
unlike Christian the fourth however
Gustavus intervention was wildly
successful
fortunately for Sweden fallen Steen had
been dismissed by the distrustful and
preferred inand in 1630 leaving Tilly is
the best commander available in 1630
Swedish forces landed here in Pomerania
which was itself Protestant and
currently fighting Emperor this began
the third stage of the war the swedish
phase once there the swedish managed to
threaten brandenburg-prussia into giving
them help Gustavus also attempted to
bring Saxony into the war but its leader
John George the first wanted to remain
neutral
Tilly fearing a Saxon Swedish alliance
invaded Saxony forcing John George to
join Gustavus out of desperation oops in
1631 a combined swedish Saxon force met
Tilly the most famous battle of the war
the Battle of Brighton felled Tilly's
much larger force was utterly crushed
and both sides met again the next year
at the Battle of rain which was another
Swedish victory and also saw Tilly
killed so the question here is why did
Sweden win where Denmark lost the answer
is complicated but Sweden had a slightly
more efficient way of recruiting and
arming soldiers the normal way was that
a noble would be asked to fund his own
soldiers which cost a lot in return for
the
spoils of war in a chance at everlasting
glory army upkeep came at the cost of
whichever region was hosting them and
was often devastating for the local
population their sweden's method of
raising troops was slightly different
for a start Sweden being Protestant men
the Gustavus was the head of the Church
of Sweden and he used local churches the
census to determine population
specifically the taxable and recruitable
population however there were still
incredible burdens on the areas of the
Holy Roman Empire which hosted the
Swedish army as for the military side
Gustavus his army focused much more on a
doctrine of masked fire and combined use
of muskets cannon and cavalry to shock
the enemy warfare was naturally moving
in this direction and both the Spanish
and Dutch had made use of this first but
Gustavus embraced this new form of
warfare to great ends so back to the war
Gustavus had marched his army through
massive waves of Imperial territory by
1632 but had to prevent the reinstated
volunteen from outmaneuvering him the
two met at the Battle of lutes in which
was a Swedish victory but did seek a
staff as Adolphus and his horse killed
in 1634 volun steam was also
assassinated on the orders of the
Emperor and so both sides had lost some
of their most proficient generals except
for the Spanish in the Dutch but they
were busy 1634 also saw the tide turn in
favor of the Habsburgs at the Battle of
nordlingen the swedish army was
obliterated by the spanish who were
commanded by Cardinal Infante Ferdinand
who were now firmly involved in the
wider war the next year saw the signing
of the Peace of Prague which saw Saxony
Brandenburg and the other Protestant
states in the Holy Roman Empire make
peace leaving only sweden against the
emperor in spain the dutch were still
fighting as well but they had their own
objectives France led by king louis xiii
and under the advice of cardinal
richelieu believed that the Peace of
Prague made the Habsburg stew powerful
and so decided on direct confrontation
the French declared war on Spain in 1635
in the Holy Roman Empire the next year
which began the French phase of the war
Richelieu had a clever strategy during
the war which was to not only fight
head-on but also to fund rebellions and
foreign armies which would force Spain
in the empire to fight a war on several
fronts
despite this things went poorly for the
French at first with Infante Ferdinand
pushing all the way to the edge of Paris
via the Spanish Netherlands the next
four years were incredibly intense
fighting with major a minor victories on
both sides it also saw and preferred now
in the second eye in 1637 and he was
succeeded by his son Ferdinand the third
so with all this fighting and turmoil
what was life like for the people of the
Holy Roman Empire to put it mildly it
was miserable the war brought horrendous
level
of starvation plunder disease poverty in
general misery to the people there these
people needed someone to blame and they
had one specific group in mind
witches persecutions of witches were
particularly severe in the Catholic
South but given the widespread
destruction of the lands across the
entire Empire nobody was really spared
the persecutions largely ended when the
swedish intervened because stopping a
foreign army was you know a bigger
priority the war was still waging
fiercely in 1640 in Spain was struggling
with Portugal and Catalonia the latter
of which had declared itself a
principality under the rule of louis
xiii portugal was being helped
financially by the french - and all of
this meant that spain had to withdraw
its troops from its possessions in the
rest of europe sweden was still fighting
in the holy roman empire and in 1642
when the Second Battle of Brighton
failed which basically gave a control
over all of the north
in the same year Cardinal Richelieu died
in louis xiii decided to follow suit the
next year leaving france with the child
king and under the Regency of Louie's
wife Anne of Austria the next year so an
important French victory require which
ended the idea of Spanish military
invincibility and showed that France was
still stable and would probably continue
its rise so by this point everyone was
getting bit sick and tired of this war
and so delegates began discussing the
terms for peace with each other these
peace talks would take many years to
come to any sort of agreement and whilst
they were ongoing Sweden found itself in
a new war this time with Denmark the
Swedish one and in the end they took all
of this territory but it did serve to
distract them somewhat from the war with
the Empire of course the Swedish would
return quickly pushing south and after
meeting up with the French continuously
defeated the Imperial forces driving
them further south in 1646 attempts to
make peace were stepped up by both sides
because this war had been raging for
literally twenty-eight years now and
everyone was a bit tired the
negotiations were held over several
years in the cities of osnabrück and
Munster in January 1648 the Netherlands
and Spain's on the Peace of Munster on
which Spain recognized Dutch
independence thus ending the eighty
years war the Hapsburgs negotiating
position was weakened in later 1648 when
the French won an immense victory at the
Battle of long the Swedish also laid
siege to Prague at this time but little
came of it after this - more peace
treaties were concluded the first was
the Treaty of Munster which made peace
between France and the Holy Roman Empire
but not Spain the second was the Treaty
of osnabrück which made peace between
Sweden and the Holy Roman Empire
collectively these are known as the
Peace of Westphalia and they had some
territorial changes
notably with Sweden France and
Brandenburg gaining these lands it also
reinstated the Peace of Augsburg
allowing religious toleration of
Calvinism and is largely considered to
be the beginning of the modern era of
international diplomacy the reason for
this is that individual states were now
treated as sovereign with no difference
in the rights of one governed by Duke a
king or an emperor this shows just how
much the war changed over the decades
from one driven by a desire of
Protestant states to protect their
fellow believers - one driven by the
geopolitical desires of France and Spain
the legacy of the 30 Years War is
complex it's or the rise of Sweden in
France and the decline of the Holy Roman
Empire is Europe central power this was
mostly because it was now entirely
decentralized but also because the
population loss within the Empire was
catastrophic and important something to
remember when discussing the wars
military glories I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching and a
special thanks to James Bissonnette for
sponsoring the channel if you'd like to
know more about the 30 Years War there
are some book recommendations in the
description below
you